hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the
central questions that's being asked in
Augustine of Hippo x' on free-choice in
the willow book one is what is the cause
of wrongdoing and that requires asking a
somewhat deeper question well what is
wrongdoing what makes certain actions
certain behaviors wrong as opposed to
being right and there's some quite
sophisticated reasoning going on in this
dialogue sometimes it seems almost by
way of digression but it actually all
holds together in one long account so
you know let's start by considering the
three examples that the student brings
up Augustine says well what what is
wrongdoing well
adultery is wrongdoing murder is wrong
doing and sacrilege is wrongdoing now
they're going to have a very interesting
discussion about what makes Daltrey
wrong and then another discussion about
what makes murder wrong they won't
actually get into sacrilege as such
although we could easily extrapolate out
from these principles something along
those lines so Augustine asks his
student of odious tell me why you think
Daltrey is wrong and one very
easy way of addressing this that the
student sees through right away but then
falls back into is a sort of appeal to
Authority human Authority Augustine says
is adultery wrong because the law
forbids it and the student says no no
that would be putting the cart before
the horse because you know the law
forbids it because it's wrong it's not
just wrong because the law says you
can't sleep with somebody else or commit
some sort of infidelity but a little bit
later he'll say you know I've seen
people condemned for this and then
Augustine says listen you already said
it's not the law itself at least the
temporal law that makes adultery a
wrongful act so the student comes up
with another explanation of it and it's
quite a good one but it doesn't
ultimately work he says I know an act to
be evil which I should not allow in the
case of my own wife so Avvo Deus is
saying I wouldn't want my own spouse to
cheat on me so that's what makes
adultery wrong it's kind of a you know
do onto others as you want to be them to
do onto you or don't do what is hateful
you know to us to others what is hateful
to you you know sort of a reciprocity
right a universalization and then
Augustine says it actually doesn't work
as well as we think it does
what about swingers they didn't have
words you know for swingers back in that
time but these are people who
deliberately engage in you could say a
violation of the typical norm of
committed relationships right he says if
a man's passion was so strong he offered
his own wife to another and freely
allowed her to be seduced by him because
he wished to have the same license with
this man's wife would he be doing no
wrong and Avvo Deus says no that would
be wrong as well and you know we might
in in our own time say well you know
what about you know consent and all that
put that aside for the moment and just
think about it in these terms he says
that would be a very great wrong what's
wrong with that
he says Augustine says he's not sinning
against the principle that you mentioned
he's not doing what he would not like
done to himself as a matter of fact he's
all for this so you have to find another
reason why adultery would be wrong why a
violation of a monogamous relationship
involving trust would be wrong and then
Augustine goes on and suggests maybe
it's something else
maybe it's not whether or not it
conforms to a law maybe it's not whether
it can be universalized or anything like
that maybe what's wrong in it is we
could say the motive what is the motive
in committing adultery well you know to
put it very bluntly you want to get laid
right but you know if we want to express
that in more technical terms
Augustine actually has a term that we
use in English sometimes to describe
this interestingly enough he suggests
that maybe it's passion and the word
that we're translating here is passion
is libido a desire right it doesn't just
mean sexual desire it means because you
can have a libido Doman handi you know a
desire to dominate others to control
others that it can take many different
forms but it's a drive it's an effect
maybe that's what's wrong in it so he
goes on and he says maybe passion is the
evil in adultery you're looking for the
evil on the outward act I'll prove that
passion of the evil in adultery if a man
has no opportunity of living with
another man's wife but it's obvious for
some reason he would like to do so and
would if he could he's no less guilty
than if he was caught in the act and
Amodeo says yeah that's that's right it
is it is in fact the motive the
affective motive in this case so he says
I see there's no need of a long argument
to convince me this is true of murder
and sacrilege and indeed of all sins
it's plain nothing else than passion is
the principal element in the whole
matter of wrongdoing so now of audience
thinks he's gotten to the bottom of the
matter
wrong-doing it's always libido and
Augustine says no it's not quite so
simple as that
let's take a look now at murder so what
sort of effect of shapes does libido
take sometimes it's desire capetti toss
right desire for something it steers us
into doing something like right now I
have a desire to explain Augustine to
you sometimes it could be fear Mateus in
Latin and fear is also an effect that
has to do with with you know libido as
well so he says what's the difference
between these and Augustine says maybe
you think it's because desire seeks its
object well fear avoids it and then he
says so if somebody kills a person not
through desire but through fear are they
doing the wrong thing are they still a
murderer and a vote iya says yes but it
doesn't follow that this act will be
free from the motive of desire if a
person kills another person through fear
it's because they desire to live without
fear and Augustine says well don't you
think that's a good thing living without
fear and avoiding it says yes but the
murder cannot gain this bias crime and
Augustine says I'm not worried about
whether he can gain this I'm worried
about whether that's what's motivating
him he desires what is good if he
desires to live without fear this desire
is free from blame otherwise we'd blame
everybody who desires what's good now
things are getting a bit more
complicated and we might think of cases
of self defense or when horrible abuse
is taking place right so he says we
cannot point to evil desire as the
dominant motive in every murder it would
be false to say that the dominance of
passion constitutes the evil in every
sin there might in fact be a murder
which was not a sin and you know
Augustine makes some clarifications here
he says that you might you know kill
somebody but
not be a murder and he says you know if
the slave kills his master because he's
afraid of being tortured do you think we
should count among we should count him
among those who kill a man without
actually deserving to be called a murder
and and you know the voting's tries to
appeal to authority and Augustine says
no no let's leave the law aside here
what do you actually think about this
and so they're going on and on about
this this issue of whether a person who
wants to live without fear has an evil
desire and it can be evil in some
respects as we'll see in just a bit but
it's not evil in the same way as
somebody who's killing their their
employer out of greed right or because
they don't want to go to jail for
example you know you embezzle from your
employer this is what true crime stuff
is made of right we have a little case
that unravels over half an hour or an
hour and it turns out that he was
embezzling the whole time and somebody
caught him you know they've got the
computer record so he kills them to
cover it up well that would be wrongful
right but let's say that instead it's
somebody who's placed in a very
difficult situation maybe it's not maybe
it's not wrong so he says when a master
is killed by a slave through this desire
not not to live in fear he's not killed
through desire we can blame we have not
yet discovered why this action is evil
we agreed that evil things are evil
because they're done through passion
that is through a blameworthy desire so
what's blameworthy about the desire
here's where Augustine is going to
deepen the analysis a bit more what
makes these these instances of desire
fear bad it's not just having desire or
fear instead it's a love a more in latin
of things that we can lose against our
will things that we can lose unwillingly
as another way of translating it without
without wanting to well what sort of
things can we lose against our will all
sorts of things right
so that's going to be something that's
going to guide us into realizing another
insight much later on in the work after
they go through a bit of a detour
through discussing some other matters
Augustine asks well what is it that
actually makes a human mind give way to
desire what compels it and the answer is
nothing actually compels it the human
mind is free because we have free wills
now that doesn't mean things can't be
made difficult for us and we can't be
made to feel all sorts of passions right
or emotions like desire and fear but we
have a choice about whether we get into
it he says the you know what we don't
have minds that are the slave of passion
because of the passion he says nothing
makes a mind give way to desire except
what its own will the volum toss the
Faculty of will and it's free choice
libre are but a libre our victim I
almost said Libra or b3 which would be
you know a different formulation so our
own choice to give in to desire our own
choice to value things in certain ways
our own is Augustine will say later love
expressed through the will is what makes
us do things wrongly or you know it
makes us desire things too strongly and
get into that desire or it leads us into
fearing the wrong things so so what are
these sorts of things well a little bit
later on he talks about this a little
bit of length he says loving other
things more than the eternal law and
one's own good will which are things we
can't lose things that can't be taken
away from us unwillingly if we want to
retain a right will that is a will by
which we live virtuously and and you
know pursue wisdom and
you know try to relive rightly and all
that it can't be taken away from us only
our own choice to abandon that by
choosing something else more can cause
us to lose that so what are these sorts
of things he says people who love other
things love things like wealth
honors pleasures physical beauty all the
other things which they may be unable to
gain though they want them and can lose
against their will these are what we
call temporal Goods and indeed they are
goods pleasure is not a bad thing
pleasures are good beauty you know
physical beauty is a good thing now
Augustine actually says that it consists
in a certain kind of ordering not in
this particular place in the text but
but later on so he says some men love
eternal things others love temporal
things and you know this is what makes
the distinction a little bit later on he
talks about the things that we cling to
the body and what are called its goods
such as sound health keen senses
strength beauty and so on
some of which are necessary for the
useful arts
then there's freedom although there is
no true freedom except for those who are
happy and cling to the eternal law but I
mean the freedom by which people think
they're free when they do not have other
people bossing them around freedom is
indeed a good and we do desire it but
it's it's a temporal good it's one we
can lose and if we value freedom more
than we value having a good will and
following the eternal law that's when we
get into problems that's when we wind up
with the the bad sort of passion he also
says there's other things as well
parents brothers wife children relations
connections friends all who are joined
to us by the same bond human beings are
good things even when they screw up
there there's still a fundamental
goodness to them
and yet if we value them more highly
than we should within the sort of vast
matrix of things we value them in the
wrong way we're gonna get ourselves in
trouble and we're going to have this
this
passion that then we give in to think
about all the people who commit
injustice for their children right
we had a very recent scandal of very
famous people committing Clery injustice
which they want some of them have gone
to jail for or at least been charged
with cheating to get their stood there
their young students into elite
institutions right spending hundreds of
thousands of dollars on this sort of
thing right why do they do that well you
could say it's love of the children or
maybe the prestige of the institution or
fear that their kid won't you know be
able to manage in life if they don't
have a Yale degree or something along
those lines right but they ultimately it
comes back to valuing things the wrong
way having the wrong ordering of love
loving temporal Goods the success of
their children more than they love
eternal goods like justice and then
everything else follows in kind of a
chain he also talked about the state
itself right and then he says money
under which a single term has included
everything of which were rightful
masters and which we are regarded as
having the power to sell and give away
any of these things can lead us away
from the eternal law and from our own
good will and when we abandon those
things the eternal law and our own good
will in favor of these temporal Goods it
is by our own choice the passion then
becomes something that we serve and are
guided by and then we do wrongful things
and that is what is wrong in these
wrongful acts like adultery or murder or
sacrilege
you